oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include
the male spiders ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it is so
crazy down there that's right folks spiderman
is in fact peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that are yours
does any part of you feel relieved
about all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't really
have to hide or lie to people for the record
i never wanted to lie to you but how do
you tell someone that you're spider-man
now everybody knows but this isn't about me
this is hurting a lot of people i've just
been thinking about how to fix all this
so peter so why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please we saved half the universe
together i think we're beyond you calling me sir
okay stephen that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my entire
life got screwed up i was wondering if maybe you
could make it so that he never did strange don't
cast that spell it's too dangerous fine i won't
the entire world is about to forget
that peter parker is spider-man
wait everyone can't some people still
know that's not how the spell works so
mj's gonna forget about everything we've
ever been through stop tampering with the
spell oh my god ned he's my best friend
oh my aunt may should really stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space time
multiverse is a concept about
which we know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying
to live two different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
Welcome back everyone it's pizza time sony and
marvel finally released the spider-man no way
home trailer so of course there's a bunch of
easter eggs we'll break it all down confirming
some of the multiverse elements from the toby
maguire spider-man movies in the andrew garfield
spider-man movies this will be my quick reaction
video i'll do a much longer full breakdown with
everything tomorrow as well if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course i'll be doing a billion videos
for all this it is like spider-man season now
between all the different spider-man movies we're
getting in the next couple of months between venom
lithography carnage spider-man no way home and
then the morbius movie in january so the big thing
here obviously you see doctor octopus from the
toby maguire spider-man movies come he's got his
arms from the toby films just confirming that he
is a version of that character from spider-man 2.
afromolina basically said that his story in the
movie picks up the minute that he goes into the
bay at the end of spider-man 2. and a lot of
that has to do with the way they're blending
multiple timelines multiple realities in the
movie and things go completely off the rails
and yes you definitely heard green goblin's
cackle from the tobey maguire spider-man
movies the willem dafoe green goblin and saw
one of his goblin bombs go off confirming the
rumors that he is going to be one of if not the
main villain of the movie pulling together the
multiverse version of the sinister six obviously
there's also the electrical blast for jamie foxx's
electro character that's just a sign of him during
the movie when they're casting the spell you see
peter in his suit down in the basement there the
sanctum and you see that inky black hand reach out
and try to swipe peter growling any being blocked
by doctor strange's magical barrier i don't think
that's meant to be venom or the symbiote i think
it's just meant to be a phantom based on some of
the doctor strange comics they'll explain during
the film like dark terrible things from other
dimensions some of their costumes look a little
bit different and i've already done a video about
all of spider-man's new costumes but the other big
easter egg that a lot of you long-time spider-man
comic book readers will recognize is that they're
basically doing the entire plot from spider-man
one more day it was a very controversial storyline
because a lot of people just absolutely hated it
because it was basically mephisto yes that
mephisto retconning spider-man's life with
mary jane during that version of events aunt may
died because of the events of their version of
civil war so spider-man goes to doctor strange
and asks for solution can you bring her back to
life doctor strange says there's no way i can do
this so obviously spider-man going to him during
this like you see the halloween decorations
with a little witch hat and is like oh yeah
i know wizard i'll go to doctor strange here's
the multiverse connection though when spider-man
in the comics eventually went to mephisto
really was mephisto trying to manipulate him
mephisto gives him a multiverse explainer like
there are other timelines out there where you
didn't become spider-man where your loved ones
that are dead in this reality are still alive so
we can mix and match those so that you get them
back and that's basically the soft explainer for
what doctor strange is doing in spiderman no way
home it's kind of a king multiverse war type of
explainer you can see how they're kind of tying
things to what happened during the loki series
remember when he who remains was tempting loki and
sylvie saying that he would give them everything
they always wanted i can give you the infinity
gauntlet i can make it so that you both live
together and you've always had this happy life
and nobody thinks it's weird that you're both
two versions of the same person that would have
been he who remains using his own command over
the multiverse to basically edit their timeline
so doctor strange is doing kind of the same thing
here but just using a magic spell to accomplish
it trying to combine a couple different realities
where spider-man's identity wasn't revealed
because mysterio never doxxed him but the comedy
of the situation being that spider-man slowly
realizes the consequences of what they're doing
that's not how the spell works peter because as
he says it will erase all memory of spider-man's
identity from everyone and that includes aunt may
all of his friends like mj ned leeds it'll also
make all the avengers characters forget about him
as well but in classic spider-man fashion based on
the plot here doctor strange yelling at him don't
mess with the spell it sounds like spider-man is
directly responsible for the way they mess the
spell up and it winds up shattering reality and
combining things in a way that they didn't
intend this still doesn't absolutely confirm
that the main villain of the film is going
to be all the sinister six villains there
could be something else at play here but at the
same time it seems like it's going to be a very
spider-man vs the sinister six kind of movie just
because there are so many sinister six characters
from different realities and yes because they are
rolling so hard on these other realities that toby
maguire spider-man movies in the andrew garfield
spider-man movies definitely 100 percent think
that they are going to have cameos at some point
during the movie maybe not huge cameos maybe just
small post credit scene moments but i think
the odds of them actually being in the movie
just shot up one thousand percent the whole idea
here though is that this is supposed to lead into
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness and now it
kind of seems like with the way things get really
crazy with all these different realities getting
blended in a bad way that sort of sets the stage
for things going completely off the rails sort of
leaning into the kang multiverse war although i'm
not expecting kang to be a character in spiderman
no way home or in doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness maybe they'll reference him at some point
during one of those movies but i don't think he's
going to be a really big villain until we get
to ant-man 3 quantum media it's just a lot of
dialogue from doctor strange is basically giving
us an explainer similar to what we got in the loki
series a lot of what he's talking about sounds
exactly what they were talking about on the loki
series we know very little about the nature of the
multiverse and how everything works everyone who's
not named kang the other big thing you probably
noticed in this that we actually do get a look at
him in the black suit there are a couple different
suits during the movie just based on some of the
materials that we've seen the black one it just
seems like they're calling the black and gold
suit but the web shooters he's got look very
doctor strange inspired a lot of the materials
that we've seen based on this seems like he uses
magic when he's wearing this suit like it somehow
integrates doctor strange's magic with aspects
of the suit we also finally get an explainer
for what's going on in all those first look
pictures that we got earlier with the snow
covering the interior of the sanctum and i love
the way that wong and doctor strange are walking
around in the sanctum like it's no big deal like
they're walking through giant snow drifts inside
the middle of the living room here in no spoilers
for shangshin the legend of the ten rings because
wong does show up in that movie before he shows
up in this movie so i'll talk more about what's
going on with him during that movie once it gets
released in theaters next week but during this
obviously they've got a costume change because
of the weather here like he's packed his bags
and is taking a vacation they also have a funny
joke referencing the events of avengers infinity
war in avengers end game like please peter don't
call me sir we save the universe together i also
love him pulling the same move on spider-man that
the ancient one pulled on him during the doctor
strange movie and then the ancient one also
pulled on the hulk during avengers end game
and i think part of the idea here too putting some
of the blame on doctor strange for what happens
with them breaking the multiverse so to speak is
the writer of doctor strange 2 said that around
this period doctor strange is sort of writing
hi he's the most powerful that he's ever been
he's just defeated thanos with the help of the
avengers so it sounds like a very iron man tony
stark kind of problem like you also help create
a lot of the problems that you wind up solving
it's the same idea with avengers age of voltron
and the creation of ultron tony stark thinking
that he could protect the world by covering it in
a suit of armor and that leading the creation of
ultron doctor strange thinking that he's powerful
enough to help erase peter from people's minds or
erase knowledge that he's spider-man from people's
minds and it is going wildly off the rails because
as wong says he shouldn't even attempt that spell
but i do love the way that they're trying to tie
all this stuff together like now it's starting
to make sense how everything is coming together
but if it wasn't clear how the sinister six
villains wind up in this reality in the main
mcu reality it's because of the way they combine
alternate timelines alternate realities and now
the title spider-man no way home makes a little
more sense like the home in the title no way home
for peter is a reference to the home that he knew
before they changed everything where everybody
knew who he was like he had this relationship
with mj in one more day comic book explainer
what they do completely erases that so at least
part of the movie is going to be him having to
go back and try to explain to all them who he is
and i think part of the idea with the sinister
six villains for them the title means no way home
if they were to go back to their home universes
or find a way to go back then they would also
go back to being dead because like for instance
doctor octopus is supposed to have died at the
end of spider-man 2. so then messing with the
alternate timelines in the multiverse basically
brings them back to life so to speak same thing
for willem dafoe's green goblin character he
died at the end of the first spider-man movie
i think what will probably happen though when we
get to the toby maguire and the andrew garfield
of it all they'll try to hold that really close to
the vest but you can see if they're bringing these
other villains from those universes to this main
mcu universe that's basically the explainer for
how tobey mcguire winds up in the movie and how
andrew garfield spider-man winds up in the movie
there have been so many rumors about what
they're doing in the film like i said i'm
really just expecting small cameos like really
small moments from them for a lot of you that
are asking about the Wandavision easter egg so
in Wandavision episode one there's a date on
the calendar that they circle with the heart that
says august 23rd so people are like wait a minute
that's the day they're releasing the trailer
did Wandavision predict the spider-man no way
home trailer the truth is is that it just wound up
being a coincidence it's a really cool coincidence
because they'd originally intended on releasing
spider-man no way home during summer during 4th of
july weekend like they always do so we would have
gotten the trailer long before august 23rd so it
wasn't so much that Wandavision was predicting
the trailer release but the bigger august 23rd
connection that you could make you could say is
an even bigger coincidence is about the two-year
anniversary of when spider-man left the mcu for
a brief period that's right you might remember
couple years ago it's been a hot minute sony
and marvel had a little falling out and for a
very short period they took spider-man out of the
mcu like no more spider-man movies we are around
the two-year anniversary of that day so i think
that's one of the reasons why they chose to just
hold the trailer till now also it's cinemacon
and they're doing a big sony presentation so of
course they wanted to show off footage for this
but like i said my longer full breakdown video
with easter eggs for everything frame by frame
we'll post tomorrow leave all your video requests
and your big questions in the comments below and
let me know what is your favorite moment from this
footage i'll update the link at the end of the
video here with that full breakdown video you
can click here for my eternals trailer breakdown
and how eternals is setting up x-men inside the
mcu thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!